jump into this so the first point is 3
comma negative 2 comma 1 and when we
graph this what we want to do is first
of all we want to set up our coordinate
access system so we've got our z axis
which actually goes vertically like this
our y axis which goes horizontally and
this x axis here you can see it's what
it's designed to do I see I've kind of
drawn it sort of like on a 45 it's
supposed to look like it's coming you
know out of the paper out of this
two-dimensional board out at at us right
and one way to think about this is as a
right-hand rule if you take your right
hand and you put your fingers in the
direction of the positive x-axis this is
the axis is coming out of the board okay
out of the paper towards us and you take
your fingers and you curl them the way
that they normally would curl so what
they're doing is they're curling towards
the positive Y axis that's this going to
the right and what happens is our thumb
points in the positive z axis so when
you're going up this is positive so you
take that right hand you curl it the way
it normally curls that's your positive z
axis this is our positive Y negative Y
going backwards okay into the board
that's our negative x and then going
down as negative Z so let's go ahead and
plot these points so a is 3 negative 2 1
and remember this is alphabetical X
comma Y comma Z so 3 we're going to go 3
in the positive x-direction now some
tips I'm going to mark up my my axes I'm
gonna draw these lines but notice how
I'm drawing them see how I'm drawing
these marks I'm drawing a parallel to
the y axis okay so it kind of gives you
that that 3d effect so we're going 3 and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to go 2 in the y direction so
that's going to be negative 2 so I'm
going to go 2 in the negative y
direction so that's going to be like
this that's going to be let's see how
can we draw this we're gonna go 1 2 now
notice how did I draw these lines I drew
them parallel to the x axis okay and so
what I'm gonna do now is I'm going to
draw like a parallelogram but basically
see how I'm drawing this like this you
can draw this dashed or dotted but what
I did is I try to draw these lines
parallel to the you know to the other
axis so that it gives you that you know
that flat like you're looking at it out
in 3d and then over here we've got the z
axis just one so we're going up 1
okay on our z axis like this and so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to I'm
gonna draw this like as a a box
essentially so what I'm doing is I'm
going like this and going up one here
again I'm drawing a box like this and
I'm always trying to see parallel okay
so something like like this like that
and you can do a little bit better you
can practice as you do this but what
this does is you can see this box you
can see it's kind of like coming you
know out at us and you can see that it's
elevated above this XY plane is going up
one so this is our point eight